splatoon is a light-hearted sugar-coated
game that's landed on the back of
today's dark and gritty shooters it's
exceptional because it redefines the
rules of shooters stripping away
violence and aggression in the name of
innocent fun splatoon makes you look at
your environment and opponents in ways
that no other game has before yes it's
the perfect game for people who want the
shooter experience without all the
killing but it's also a fantastic
shooter by any standard splatoon's
colorful city of inkopolis is populated
by hybrids squid humans known as
Inklings these guys and gals can take
the form of either animal on command and
to then ink is everything Inklings are
in themselves for work and play with
weapons such as squirt guns and paint
rollers need more ammo to knock out
opponents of spreading
turn into a squid and take a dip to
watch the tank on your back fill up ink
swatches from these weapons are also
great for swimming and hiding granting
you much-needed speed and stealth during
hectic matches multiplayer splatoon's
bread and butter but there's a fair
amount to do on your own to inkopolis is
source of power the great zapfish is
held captive by the invading octarians
they're roughly thirty stages between
you and the great zapfish but because
individual levels are so short
consisting of some platforming and light
combat the ride doesn't last as long as
you'd like if you pick up some Nintendo
splatoon amiibos you can use those to
unlock special challenges for these
stages that will net you new gear and
while it's a nice option to have you're
ultimately playing through the same
levels but also paying extra for the
privilege splatoon is ultimately about
multiplayer where you are required to
begin your playtime in turf wars the
goal here is to paint as much of the map
in your team's ink before a three minute
timer runs out inking new ground
stealing coverage from your enemies and
knocking out opponents makes these
matches fun and because there are so
many ways to make a difference rather
than by being a sharpshooter alone
splatoon rewards you with a constant
flow of small wins the way no other
shooter really does once you hit level
10 you can dive into rank matches which
currently feature one new match type
splat zones in splat zones two teams
fight for control over a small area
within the middle of a map and whichever
team controls the area by covering in
ink for 100 seconds is ultimately
declared the winner
unlike turf wars where everyone earns
points to level up and purchase gear in
ranked battles to the winners only go
the spoils
given that splatoon's multiplayer is
exclusively team-based it's frustrating
that it's impossible to strategize as a
group voice chat is non-existent and
because entire loadouts are determined
by your primary weapon and teams are
assigned randomly you may end up on a
team
player has the same loadout in a
situation where your team is homogeneous
the odds are rarely in your favor you
earn points during matches for covering
turf and knocking out enemies and you
can spend these on new headgear guns
Footwear or shirts points also determine
how fast you level up which in turn
affects what new gear unlocks in each
store with bonuses that impact speed
power and defense it's important to keep
your eye on what that new shirt you're
eyeing does besides merely looking cool
between turf wars splat zones and
unlocking new gear not to mention the
single-player content there's a lot to
chew on in splatoon yet it still feels a
tad light don't get me wrong
splatoon is so fun to play that you
rarely care I want more single-player
content to explore and control over
multiplayer so that I can craft specific
types of multiplayer matches rather than
taking whatever comes my way I want more
splatoon because I like it and also
because there's not enough variety in
the things you can do over a long period
of time unfortunately there are also
some problems in the short term splatoon
only lets you play one of three maps for
the better part of an entire day and you
never get your chance to vote or pick
your next map Nintendo's foray into
shooter territory does stumble on
occasion but when I'm swimming through
ink covering my environment in neon and
drinking in the quirky city of inkopolis
I'm far more aware of how unique its
mechanics are and how enjoyable it is to
play one match after another splatoon is
a wonderful game who's inventive ideas
paved the way for new experiences in an
otherwise stale category of games
you